le 22 novembre pour leur première
rencontre du Mondial 2022 l'équipe de
France affrontera l'Australie mais à 5
jours du coup d'envoi les Bleus font
aujourd'hui face à une polémique ces
mots du golioris qui ne portera pas de
brassard aux couleurs de la communauté
LGBT alors que le président de l'afff
Noël le Grey a déconseillé aux joueurs
de porter un brassard arc-en-ciel pour
soutenir la cause LGBT le capitaine de
l'équipe de France Hugo Lloris s'est
exprimé à son tour sur le sujet bien sûr
j'ai mon opinion personnelle et
ça rejoint un petit peu celle du
président pour se justifier le gardien
de 35 ans explique qu'il compte
respecter la culture du Qatar ne pas
porter des messages politiques quand on
est un sportif une démarche qui fait
même réagir au plus haut sommet de
l'État je pense qu'il faut pas politiser
le sport alors comprenez vous que le
capitaine de l'équipe de France refuse
de porter le brassard LGBT
alors oui oui oui
non
c'est pas au joueur d'être des hommes
politiques sur cette coupe du monde s'il
voulait l'être il fallait que toute la
nation boycott on y va donc on respecte
la loi du Qatar alors pas la loi du
Qatar quand c'est persécuté les
homosexuels bien entendu je suis contre
ça mais on est au Qatar on doit
s'adapter et les joueurs ne peuvent pas
arborer comme ça des brassards
d'ailleurs c'est interdit par la FIFA et
la fédération ne voulait pas non plus
Didier Deschamps non plus donc la FIFA
Fédération internationale de football
[Rires]
donc je comprends cette décision la FIFA
toute façon ils ont pas de couilles ça
va toi mais en fait toi tu t'es cruches
ta mère
il a pas dit un mot de toutes les
missions la première fois
s'il te plaît je suis sur le rocher mais
tu arrêtes toi alors tu donneras ton
avis dans un instant intelligiblement
comme tout le monde ici regardez tu veux
entendre quelqu'un d'intelligible
il fallait il fallait effectivement ce
révolter il y a 10 ans quand ils ont eu
la candidature avec du 4 Messi
honnêtement maintenant lever le bras
c'est tout les bobos derrière
la seule qui peut le voir c'est Amel
Bent et honnêtement en fait maintenant
des débats politisés le débat demandé
aux joueurs de faire c'est de faire ça
il fallait que c'est la lune il fallait
pas donner la Coupe du Monde au Qatar à
arrêter maintenant de faire des dégâts
qui ne servent à rien effectivement il a
un il a raison c'est pas c'est pas le
rendu de l'équipe de France déjà et de
deux c'est que ça m'énerve que
maintenant tout est fait et les gens ils
se lève à faire un scandale mais les
mecs réveillez-vous depuis 10 ans
maintenant
oui moi je trouve que les sportifs sont
représentants de leur nation sont
ambassadeurs de leur nation et l'équipe
de France est donc un symbole aussi du
du message de bah de l'Occident de
l'ouverture d'esprit je suis désolé et
si déjà ils ont pas pris position pour
la cause environnementale et Ben qui
peuvent envoyer un message d'ouverture
par rapport à toutes ces communautés qui
sont persécutées donc je trouve ça très
bien si tous les joueurs de l'équipe de
France portent ce brassard
monsieur l'argument d'Hugo Lloris il est
implacable on n'arrête pas de dire qu'en
France il faut respecter les valeurs et
les règles de la France là ils sont au
Qatar ils doivent respecter ses règles
et arrêtez de direct
homophobe ça n'a rien à voir c'est son
choix mais si parce que c'est ça les
polémiques les raccourcis qui sont faits
c'est illumophobe il a un malaise avec
l'homosexualité ça n'a rien à voir cette
Coupe du Monde c'est une grande fête
populaire laissez les gens qui fait les
spectateurs qui fait les joueurs qui
fait c'est pas parce qu'on joue au Qatar
que on est homophos là parce qu'on
refuse de mettre un brassard qu'on est
homophobe c'est une grande fête
populaire arrêtez de créer des
polémiques partout et de tout politiser
c'est insupportable la tristesse alors
Mathieu je vais te laisser la parole
après
Géraldine moi j'aurais adoré qu'il le
porte j'aurais trouvé ça extraordinaire
j'aurais trouvé que c'était un symbole
fort alors évidemment il suit les
injonctions de du président de de la
Fédération Française de foot de
l'Ogresse pour le coup la FFF
personnel il pensait que c'était bien à
partir du moment où on allait dans un
pays de respecter les règles du pays moi
je trouve que c'est une régression alors
oui j'entends le côté il fallait pas
donner à 10 ans et tout ça et ouais mais
mais malgré tout en fait on va là-bas et
Amnesty internat international dit qu'il
faut qu'on soit des lanceurs d'alerte
donc moi je trouve que c'est quand même
très très important pour l'environnement
pour les droits des salariés pour les
droits LGBT excusez-moi là-bas les gens
ils vont en prison les gens ils risquent
leur vie les gens ils sont tués parce
qu'ils sont homosexuels donc je sais que
tout le monde s'en fout non c'est que
tout le monde s'en fout je trouve
Gilles excuse-moi mais d'une hypocrisie
crasse parce que quand gay le du PSG n'a
pas voulu mettre le maillot LGBT qui
avait été une injonction pourtant de la
Ligue tu avais dit oui mais c'est bon on
était en France
alors en France pardonne-moi
l'homophobie c'est un vrai problème et
quand on met le débats
ne respecte pas les règles en France
alors toi mais là maintenant on est au
Qatar alors on fait comme on veut Qatar
ok pourquoi pas mais malgré tout à ce
moment-là pourquoi Gaëlle ne le fait pas
en France donc je trouve que c'est une
hypocrisie et je trouve qu'on aurait dû
on aurait dû le faire parce qu'il y a
plein de pays européens qui le font et
Voilà il se trouve que c'est moi ça me
désole moi je trouve que s'il avait
porté ça aurait été honteux parce que
justement c'est tellement grave parce
qu'il y a quand même les homosexuels
musulmans risquent la peine de mort
là-bas et ils arrivent avec un petit
bracelet un petit un petit brassard
essentiel
moi j'aurais trouvé ça mais j'aurais
trouvé ça plutôt de mettre un petit un
petit truc arc-en-ciel pour des choses
aussi
il fallait pas venir du tout
écouter ce que dit c'est ridicule le
président de la République là-dessus
parce que c'est exprimé là-dessus manuel
Macron écoutez
il faut pas politiser le sport et la
vocation d'abord ces questions-là il
faut se poser quand on attribue les
événements c'est quand on attribue des
jeux qui souhaitent des Coupes du Monde
ou des choses olympiques qu'il faut en
toute honnêteté c'est poser la question
et que la question soit climatique ou
qu'elle soit des droits de l'homme il
faut pas se les poser à chaque fois que
l'événement est là
c'est au moment où on l'attribue qu'on
doit se la poser
je suis désolé je trouve que le
président a défendu son équipe de France
je te jure sur un sujet aussi important
au capitaine de l'équipe de France c'est
beaucoup de respect pour lui mais il est
très intelligent la conférence de presse
maintenant
je ne t'apporter de brassard par respect
pour la culture du pays mais pardon
l'homosexualité c'est pas une culture
je connais bien Hugo je connais bien
l'équipe de France
eux ils se retrouvent dans une situation
l'équipe de France les pauvres gars ils
sont là pour jouer au foot ils sont là
et on les met dans des polémiques dans
lesquels
je sais pas c'est pas eux parler
il a rajouté cette phrase on ne peut pas
cautionner tout ça mais chacun est
d'avoir ton opinion
horrible il a dit c'est pas bien ce qui
se passe là-bas mais en France on n'est
pas là pour donner des leçons en fameux
de regarder ce qui se passe chez nous
bah pardon chez nous mais pas les
homosexuels en prison Emmanuel Macron
c'est toujours la première fois que je
suis d'accord avec lui quand même
politique en lui il se bat pour que
mapper reste en France en disant il faut
me bats les restes en France bah P c'est
la France et tout excusez-moi c'est
politique le foot c'est quand même
politique moi je trouve alors on a pas
entendu Castaldi après je voudrais voir
un très bon article ce matin dans un
journal aussi ouais alors Mathieu
je pense que le Président je vous l'ai
dit que je trouvais que c'était un débat
et tu vois c'est pas rentrer dans ma vie
voilà donc effectivement je pense à
parler aussi
allez vas-y alors quand je ta valve il
faut arrêter de politiser le sport pour
la première fois je suis d'accord avec
Emmanuel Macron je regrette qu'il est
pas fait la même chose pour les Russes
quand ils ont été évincés toutes les
compétitions il faut arrêter de
politiser le sport quand on a un Iranien
par exemple dans des compétitions de
judo qui refusent la compétition avec un
Israélien au nom de la politique tout le
monde est scandalisé là il faut laisser
ce sont des jeunes de 22 25 ans ils
viennent juste pour jouer au foot faut
les laisser tranquille ils peuvent pas
porter le poids de sujets aussi lourd en
plus à l'époque du racisme quand tu
mettes leur genou à terre par exemple ça
leur pose pas de problème
quand tous les joueurs sont contre le
racisme quand tout est joueurs se
montrent l'homophobie la revanche ça
pose un problème c'est gênant je
rappelle que l'homosexualité c'est pas
une question de culture c'est une
question de liberté individuelle que
là-bas on va en prison de 1 à 3 ans
c'est aussi grave que le racisme
très intéressant qui disait
qu'effectivement si on avait fait alors
bah c'est de la politique fiction mais
si on avait fait cette Coupe du monde
aux États-Unis pendant l'époque de
l'esclavagisme alors qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait on aurait refusé de mettre le
bandeau noir comme ça pour ne pas
choquer les autorités américaines si on
avait fait également c'était à Berlin en
36 qu'est-ce qu'on aurait fait on aurait
fait une brassard jaune pour ne pas
choquer les autorités allemandes à ce
moment-là les nazis parce qu'on était en
36 c'est s'arrêter ça ton raisonnement
non moi c'est le même que tu as fait le
même que tu as pour tes exoples là tu
l'as aujourd'hui pour ça les gens là-bas
qui meurent et tu refuses de mettre le
drapeau
il y en a il y a pas que Gilles qui a
dit oui hein
avec le plus en général
mais non c'est parce que c'est parce que
Gilles c'est c'est que il a plus de
verbes que les autres d'ailleurs
je pense que maintenant il avance un
visage démasqué
ça je ne permets pas je ne permets pas
Mathieu la cause de ma vie c'est la
lutte contre le racisme l'antisémitisme
et l'homophobie mais je l'ai déjà dit
une fois effectivement il fallait porter
un sujet on est contre l'homophobie
c'était juste un t-shirt contre
l'homophobie en France
les joueurs ne le porte pas Mathieu ah
bon tu vois pas recommencer sur Gilles
Daniel voulait dire un truc
non non mais juste moi par exemple
pourquoi je mets oui je suis d'accord
là-dessus je suis pas d'accord sur ce
qu'il dit c'est honteux et je te trouve
dommage qu'on envoie des petits jeunes
comme ça dans une conférence de presse
aussi importante sans biscuits
d'opinion et de culture tu entièrement
raison on peut être oui
de France refuse de porter le glaçage
74,4 % des gens pensent que oui et non à
25 % euh merci
à vous et après le président
parce que pense c'est normal on va
soutenir l'équipe de France quoi
de de la Fédération effectivement lui
qui me pose un vrai problème et qui dit
qu'il faut pas donner de leçon aux
autres bah s'il faut de quand même
donner des sons en France effectivement
l'homosexualité n'est pas un crime et je
lui ai dit que effectivement la plupart
des pays même États-Unis Pays-Bas
Angleterre Allemagne tout Suisse un
avion éventuellement ou un logo ou un
ballon ou un drapeau
avec une
pour
moi
[Musique]
merci merci à vous de rien on en parlera
de façon pendant la coupe du monde
parce que la Coupe du monde ça va durer
un mois